tell me if you think this is a good idea
or a bad idea watch this it looks like a
sea of skin and tattoos
these images released by El Salvador's
government shows the transfer of about 2
000 inmates stripped to their shorts and
with their heads shaved to what's been
dubbed the country's new Mega prism it
just opened it's believed to be the
largest prison in the Americas with a
capacity for forty thousand people and
it's the latest step in a controversial
Crackdown on crime that's caused the
country's prison population the soar
watch the stat Stone rights
organizations have reported that
innocent people have been caught up in
the law enforcement campaign
that includes dozens notice all their
faces are covered so these guys don't
remember
last year the country's president asked
Congress for emergency panels to
temporarily suspend some constitutional
rights after a massive spike in murders
attributed to gang crime includes that
arrests can be made without a warrant
and detainees no longer have a right to
a lawyer private Communications of all
citizens can also be accessed by the
government since then about 64 000
suspects have been arrested the murder
reports fell about 57 percent did you
hear that yeah okay go back go back 10
seconds to hear that stat again it's
important for the audience to hear that
go right there right there and play it
listen to the staff the government since
then about 64 000 suspects have been
arrested the murder reports fell about
57 percent wow
okay so pause it commentary on it is
wild uh this Reuters for whatever reason
flagged this for me and said warning
they put a warning on this tweet because
it might have sensitive content I'm like
this is not even my tweet I'm retweeting
a Reuters tweet and Reuters didn't get
the warning I got the warning I'll send
it to you Rob if you want to put it up
there so is this a good idea or is this
a bad idea with what El Salvador is
doing 64 000 people arrested crime is
down 57 percent I think it's great I
think it's great um I I think people
need to go back and take a look at what
really happened in California when
Kamala Harris was attorney general the
three strikes law uh wacken Hut uh
building more prisons here which is
prisons for profit and you see what
happened in California they were trying
to drop the uh the crime rate too and so
I I think what they're trying to do they
have this they have this terrible crime
problem and they're like all right let's
just round up all the MS-13 gang members
and let's watch the statistics and
unless they're monkeying with the
numbers
um
you've got a 57 drop murders okay well
guess what's happening they're getting
the outcome they wanted and you could
debate whether you like the way they're
doing it but this is the outcome they
wanted less murders in their community
was that drastic measure times calls for
drastic measures if the yo and the stats
don't lie 50 murder rate down I'm sorry
bro if you look like that and you're
doing some gangster [__] but bye I have
no remorse zero yeah my what what is
even the push back here
go to the tweet and let's read some of
the comments I think that's the best
thing to do just go to the tweet and
let's read some of the comments uh yeah
go to the Tweet so zoom in a little bit
so we can so tough on Chrome is good but
not by suspending their constitution so
click on it to read the replies that's
Jake shields uh I agree okay I agree but
at the same time if you legitimately
commit violent crimes you forfeit your
rights the only area of concern is the
judicial system being corrupt innocent
people being convicted agreed agree okay
let's read then how many innocent people
die because certain individuals weren't
in police custody go to the next one I
was in El Salvador before they were uh
rounded up and your life was in danger
every second you left your house this is
good makes me happy citizens that want
to just make a living focus on being
harder on crime focus on punishing
criminals focusing on squeezing as many
criminals in one place as possible can
only lead to bad outcomes
um instead Focus needs to be shifted
from punishing people to rehabilitating
criminal here we go into functioning
citizens okay how do you do that is the
question everyone's asking right I've
only
I've known family members that we hope
could be rehabilitated the unfortunate
reality is that the probability of
success is quite low the cartel was
terrorizing your town murdered your
family members I have a feeling you
would say something different Bingo huh
yeah okay during the time which
resembles 1930s previous decade marked
by conflict and eroding world order to
covet declining institutional trust as
multiple layers and across the world
Spectrum I feel this doesn't end here my
mother is a in law is El Salvadorian she
grew up there and just went on vacation
there and came back last week she said
she felt so much safer this time than
any time she can remember they could
stay out and go to restaurants at night
she thanked God for it wow I mean these
this is this is the great thing about a
platform like this because you're seeing
different sides and arguments people are
making go ahead well I mean we say this
all the time about the number one thing
a mother is concerned is her kids and
are her kids what's the s word safe so
if you're we're just trying to we talk
about if you could go live anywhere and
start a country where would you go the
number one thing is are you safe and it
just would seem to be with all these
gang members running around El Salvador
just people don't feel safe and you know
numbers don't live murder has gone down
53 yeah since they've started rounding
up the MS-13 gang members uh the numbers
speak for themselves I think it's a
great thing you know I I I I I get why
there is some pause for a concern you
know are you eliminating the
Constitution whatever that was yeah
whatever they were doing wasn't working
yeah it was a murder it was a murderous
country yeah so uh kudos for taking some
action did you you guys saw what I saw
every single one of those guys they look
identical
same shaved heads dude those guys don't
need to be on public and that's that's
MS-13 those guys are they're not just
regular gang members or those guys are
ruthless bro they're nuts but look at
that all the same guy very easy to
identify you if you want tattoos on your
head body by the way there's a speech
that the Press president of El Salvador
gave okay
um is it still uh is the country that
has been the Bitcoin company yes is that
the same guy yes oh about time they
cleaned this up it's the same guy that's
been he's doing a hero of the crypto
he's doing it okay great it's making
sense by the way he gave a speech it's
on my Instagram account yeah it's two
minutes long it's an it's in Spanish but
there's a what do you call it captions
there
you have to read the speech he gives it
gives me it's it's a long time ago it's
like probably three weeks ago I posted
this it gives me the chills if you can
keep going down you'll find it it gives
me the chills on the message right there
right there he gives this message we
don't have to play it right now but you
know uh uh the the way he talks he says
we know we're a small country we know
our limits but we're not going to stay
small okay we're not here to just be
another country in El Salvador you guys
think big you guys have great things we
respect you a lot we respect what you've
done but we want to be there as well the
guy speaks like a guy you want speaking
on behalf of your country that's not
apologizing he's saying our crime is
this he's saying all this up but we're
gonna get better and we're going to be a
great country versus apologizing
constantly for being white apologizing
for believing in capitalism apologizing
for being a country that's whooped on
everybody being ashamed of who you are
there's a lot of Pride to the way this
man speaks yeah leaders who have pride
in their nationality in their country in
their people understanding to stay
humble stay you know a
reasonable individual he sounds like
someone like that he doesn't raise his
voice he speaks very calmly if you've
not heard the speech before highly
recommend watching the speech it's
powerful so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign